you know what's annoying is that I've
seen this puzzle and I don't I I don't
remember the solution that's the problem
don't even have a move for
you okay what you got boy 10
seconds um I don't know I'll probably
blender my queen with queen of5 or
something otherwise yeah I don't know
tell me I don't have any Knight D4 or
something what you got man you like move
my queen somewhere when you went if no
wrong literally insane
what you got what you got okay I got it
Bishop G3 King G5 Bishop H4 King H4
Queen H1 King G5 Queen H5 you cannot
move to F6 Queen C5 King H5 Knight F4
Knight C E6 Knight C5 oh my gosh ah okay
Bishop G3 King G5 Bishop H4 King H4
Queen H1 and queen H5 and queen H5
beautiful that's it got it first one for
n back oh Bishop G3 King G5 you have
Bishop H4 take Queen H1 Queen H5 Knight
F4 G3 and Knight E6 and Knight okay got
him that's it